hi my name is Jasmine hurry in premiums
I want I remember any time on the
virtual new graphic me and among the
many things and see names are at singing
parts right here I did another part that
i asked you Sports Complex I'm going to
go here primarily for watching men's and
women's basketball games but this caused
him is also go home on the volleyball
gymnastics and wrestling
campus and as a hotel on top a booth or
in amazement and it also has a golden
yellow this is a historical android
games and i was the university campus
isn't hers middle waterh2o one of the
nicest campuses in the country
university her where my law that's a
multi-language and it's in here this is
an example of some strange face here and
mind me is the cabin dealing with his
the iot of power sign on on the top
floor is that apple in his restaurants
near in the legends restaurant you can
get some of the nicest views of the Iowa
State campus we are going to go up there
and show you some of those meals
door
Oh
power for you to heal
right
around period
person I would mean Trading Places
wanted I could with me John Vincent and
ass off it was a technological far and
is credited with a mention in the first
working computer here at Iowa State
University and somebody gave me a free
ticket any place in the world where I
wanted his oh I would go to Hawaii is he
Volcanoes National Park but I would also
if I had another free ticket I would go
to Tanzania visit the Serengeti to see
all the wildlife and as I got another
free ticket I would go and see an
article is it pretty pretty cool nice a
name for the be I use various atlases
match record is best c'mere names i also
have looked at meetings i'm a senior
weapon and say you're my older brother
Matthias I made it to the final round of
the National Geographic me in 2004 and I
was the leader of the world are they
from diamonds are the tackle one being
religious persecution because education
isn't really fair and the sling drinking
is that's not fair either
when we're crap is this have you ever
wanted to know where the danube river
starts and starts in Germany where the
briga and brig come together your don't
out etching it
you